ah bon on est on est là on est parti on
va faire des parties avec les
spectateurs
j'attends une petite seconde parce que
je suis en train de dd notre ami vlad
fin du coup j'ai passé ma femme stream
qui devait démarrer mais il a un petit
souci informatique
donc je suis en train de lui donner un
coup de main il ya un tout petit peu de
bruit autour de moi mais mais ça va ça
va bientôt se régler mais je rappellerai
tonton lattes pour finir l'assistance
quoi finir l'assistance l'assistance à
tonton blad dont on l'attaqué qui a
parfois besoin de de l'ombre de kef du
coup pour pour régler ces petits soucis
d'avoir commencé on va voir on va voir
et je disais aujourd'hui oui donc je
vais faire des parties contre les
spectateurs donc je vous attends
j'espère que vous serez nombreux
on va laisser on va laisser le stream
démarrer les gens arrivés petit à petit
je vais vérifier qu'ils soient bien sûr
tu as comme tv non je suis pas sûr que
c'est bizarre mais j'ai l'impression que
ça marche que je ne sais pas si je vais
écrire sur le tchat
salut tout le monde si si ça va ça se si
si si c'est bon
je voudrais tu chasses points comme tv
pour voir si on est sur le oui voilà on
est on est on est on est sur le truc de
chasse comme on dit aux joueurs des deux
chattes et donc défier moins sûr tu as
comme je suis là pour vous défoncer en
fait sûr que mon objectif c'est de c2c
de vous battre évidemment mais si tu
veux rappeler vlad sur skype
il faut que tu tu le trouves à illéla
vlad blitz donc
toujours pas de toujours pas de défi bon
bah écoutez les mecs si dans une minute
ou deux j'ai pas de défi je vais
commencer à faire des bulles est et
après on va y aller par et après on aura
beau défi pour écouter je vais faire
quelques bulles est et on va prendre les
défier on va on va prendre les défis
après j'ai pas trop ce qu'ils foutent
sur le tchat
je comprends pas forcément salue à cet
chacha sont que mon tweet chez mon chat
switchback un peu je sais pas en tout
cas pour les utilisateurs mais on va on
va prendre les bullet à on a un premier
bond à mathay faire allez hop ça c'est
du connu reconnu mata faire on va le
poutre et on va le foot ralliant à lui
faire une scandinaves on va lui faire
une scandinave des familles à matha
faire on va pas on va pas reprendre le
pion des cinq on va essayer de on va
essayer de le martyriser matin faire on
va essayer de le [ __ ] et à la dure on
va essayer de le poutre et à la dure de
chez dur nous y mettre le feu orange et
on va lui faire un genre de rock opposé
boom h5
on va le mettre sous pression la têt
faire on va le mettre en sueur on va le
mettre en sueur total c'est très mauvais
un ce que je viens de faire
il va sûrement pouvoir faire du h3 ou
quoi et on va mettre la dame en a cinq
on menace un peu fou prend un f3
foudroyé froides à me ranger 5
alors ça faut savoir un les mecs que les
attaques latérales comme ça
souvent les gens à ce niveau-là 1400 le
rate mais matière ne rate pas mais il me
donne me donne la paire de fous mon fou
va être règne sur les qui va régner sur
les cases noires il est maître et il m'a
ouvert la colonne j'ai donc ma colonne
j'ai complètement ouverte je vais
pouvoir m'en servir pour défoncer son
roi donc là vous voyez il m'a fait h3 on
a on peut utiliser prendre le pion et
ont fait mal sur sept sur sept colonnes
j'ai donc la matte qui en sus art total
il est en train de se dire je me fais
poutrer par miss stream
là il est vraiment en train de se dire
ça la poutre la poutre donc là il joue
cavalier h4 il défend son pion g2 et on
va rajouter de la pression sur ce pion
g2 en jouant dame g5 donc d'amener ça
qu'on a deux idées on vient menacer une
nouvelle fois j'ai deux et on s'en prend
à son cavalier h4 qui était venu lui
même protégé g2 et cif et g3 pour
protéger son cavalier c'est exactement
ce qu'ils jouent le pion g est toujours
cloué 1 vous voyez bien le pion g et
clouer et donc après dame prend h4 et
bien il ne peut pas reprendre le la dame
évidemment et on menace maintenant tout
reprend j'ai trois pions pranger trois
dames pranger trois échecs roitg est
d'alger de maths et matt fr il m'a fait
faire qu il porte bien son nom alors
matt pourquoi avec de thé parce que là
ça sont plus tôt le matin avec un pe
odetta qu'un donc fou j'ai trois et on
va le finir à la très dur là alors non
là si on prend prend prend rouach 1 il
va protéger la cage et deux avec le fou
alors là on a plein d'options dans
l'embarras du choix
attention dame prend des quatre serait
une erreur parce que réfute france et
six échecs on perdrait la dame mais on
peut le finir alors comment est ce qu on
le finit comment est-ce qu'on se mijote
le mat à faire bon on a vraiment
beaucoup d'options que j'espère fou
prend ici on va avoir une tour de plus
nette
mais on a envie de peut-être être un
petit peu violent on va être dans la
violence donc on va faire fou d6bels
food et si c'est peut-être cavalier e 4
on écoute et on va faire dans le
pragmatisme alors
on va faire dans le pragmatisme je sais
me manque pas je réfléchis je vois plein
de positions gagnantes nom va juste
prendre fin il va reprendre et on va
prendre en d4
quand on parle et qu'on essaye de faire
les choses propres on commence à voir
des fantômes et on va prendre en d4
donc comme ça on va se retrouver avec
une tour de plus offert un poids la
tension roy qui a encore un petit peu
vulnérable on va ramener la dame en b si
c'est sûr dam des trois pour menacer
m'attendais 7 on aura tour des huit donc
là notre objectif maintenant ça va être
des changes et les pièces et de gagner
la partie alors là on a un petit chipeau
au passage quand même tout reprend g3
alors est ce qu on le fait ou ne fait
pas tout ranger 3 il va venir avec le
rouage de ça pourrait fonctionner mais
on va la jouer à la sobre on va faire
flouer 7
on va préparer l'arrivée de la tour en
des huit on va échanger des pièces on va
gagner comme ça vous arrange et 3 gagne
aussi
c'était probablement même plus fort un
j'aurais pu revenir avec la tour angers
5 et sur damas trois jolies dames preuve
de ce que j'avais pas vu avec le roi en
géant et donc sur cavani quatre ombres
f5 et et on sera très bien f5
on s'en prend aux cavaliers
il va être obligé de bouger si viande et
6 on va prendre ça nous aura permis
d'échanger encore des pièces
il prendre avec la tour on mettra le 7
pour éviter tout point réussie c'est la
tour en des 8es on va échanger encore
des pièces donc là l'idée vraiment avec
les noirs c'est d'échanger le maximum de
pièces et de se retrouver laurent le
c'est donc pour éviter tout reprend
russie ce qui était une menace pour
jouer sur le sur le pion à vii est
maintenant tour à des 8
donc voilà c'est exactement la variante
que je vous disais tout à l'heure et on
rentre encore une nouvelle fois dans des
échanges donc maintenant les tours vont
disparaître de l'échiquier
on essaye de gagner proprement un centre
utilisé tactique à la fin d'un prend
propose les changes des dames
ah bon il menace rien donc on va faire
on a tellement barre à gauche on va
refaire d'un v6 menacé le pion bessette
et ça nous permet sur damas trois
d'avoir dame b 4 pour couvrir un maximum
de case hors jeu contre une dame seule
pour l'attaqué on va essayer de faire f4
pour s'en prendre aux pions et faire
jouer notre tour de plus les changes des
dames c'est une énorme erreur de la part
des blancs il doit tenter de contrôler
jeu il aurait dû jouer avec les dames et
là il va perdre la partie complètement
perdue donc ne surtout pas échanger les
dames c'était le seul moyen d'essayer de
me poser problème bon et maintenant on
va pousser les pions au centre va
ramener le roi
on pousse on mélange 5 ne peut
absolument rien se passer avec ses pions
le cavalier en d4 qui fait une focale
sur le fou et la tour de plus qui va qui
peut venir jouer à tout moment on peut
jouer car être on peut jouer tour ici
bon on va faire tourner les scènes juste
pour s'amuser pas complètement paralysé
son fou qui est pris comme dans une
toile d'araignée et maintenant f4 ont
continué à échanger
on va faire 3 on pousse et on prend fin
mais on peut tout faire
on peut prendre en g3 prendre trois
on peut reprendre de 3 on peut prendre
en g3 alors pendant g3 annonce quelques
cavaliers mais on la prend 2,3 avec l'
idée toute bête de faire deux échecs ou
faire aux deux et je voulais carrément
je pensais qu'il allait faire froid et
faim pour y changer encore plus de
pièces donc maintenant on va se mettre
bon wagon complètement donné une
cavaliers tour pranger 3 on va amener le
roi en face du sien on va couper le roi
de la colonne f
et on va pousser comme des brutes f4f 3f
de f1 dame f2 tourer et maintenant on
pousse le pion f
et on y arrive et voilà une petite
partie sympa tosh je sais pas si ça vous
a plu
donc j'espère que cette partie vous a
plu n'hésitez pas à re faire du
challenge je vais mettre mes lunettes
parce que je dois vous dire que je vois
pas trop parfois j'ai ce problème je
vois plus trop sur l'écran on va rejouer
contre matt alors on va lui jouer eux
quatre femmes et lunettes des 5 alors on
va essayer de jouer eux 5 avec l'idée de
faire jouer à matha faire donc une
position qui n'est pas forcément très
bonne puisque après fouet f5 des quatre
est aussi son jour et une défense
française
je vous montrerai ça après la partie on
reviendra dessus mon jour et une défense
française avec le fou qui est sorti et
là ce qui se passe c'est que matt fr
vient de faire un truc pas terrible donc
l'ajout c3 puisque je voudrais bien
souligné après je vais tenir mon centre
et on joue une variante davance de la
française avec lecavalier en c6 donc le
cavalier en c6 est très mal placé
pourquoi parce que il devrait jouer ces
cinq pour pouvoir contre attaquer mon
centre hélas ce qui lui arrive c'est
qu'il peut pas contre attaquer mon
centre il jouait pts 6 son centre mon
sens très très bien installé son centre
est inexistant la f6 c'est un
affaiblissement s'il avait mis le pion
g6 on aurait joué fou prend g6 et on
aurait gagné le pion puisqu'il pouvait
pas faire à alger d'un prend la fuite
et maintenant on va continuer
tranquillement avec cavaliers f3 sur f
prend on va faire f prend va ouvrir
encore les lignes et le centre est
complètement tenus
on va faire petit rock ont essayé je
vais très tranquillement sans se prendre
la tête
faux et 8 pas mal joué il s'en prend à
la dame
damages 3 on s'en prend aux pions alors
il peut peut-être fermer le jeu avec f 5
1 et je vais peut-être pas de la manière
la plus précise mme on essaye de
l'étouffer tranquillement sans utiliser
trop tactique une nouvelle fois parce
que je sais que les joueurs amateurs ont
du mal à utiliser de la tactique nous on
essaye de se concentrer sur la stratégie
alors cavaliers f5 alors là il ya deux
possibilités soit on prend en f 5 pions
prend d'un prend et on gagne un pion et
on a une excellente position mais
peut-être sont fous s'activent
ou alors on joue avec g4 lecavalier var
devoir
tourné en racheter ce sera sa seule case
on pourra faire f5 pour ouvrir les
lignes en face de son roi et c'est
l'option que je vais choisir donc f4 g4
je prends de l'espace cavally h6 seule
case et f5 comme ça je vais ouvrir mon
fou de cases noires et je vais vouloir
jouer f prend vous voyez j'ai la tour
qui est en face de son roi donc là un
poil de tactique on a obligé fou prend
h6 donc on supprime encore une pièce de
l'adversaire et on va pouvoir attaquer
son roi bon ok il prend donc il veut
prendre en charge six plus tard alors
c'est pas mal joué de sa part
alors ici comment est-ce qu'on va se
débrouiller
on va prendre une fois angers 7 prend
danger quatre maîtres laurent achard
ils nous proposent des changes des fous
on va mettre le cavalier en h4
on va jouer sur le clouage du fou il
défend donc là le roi noir est toujours
très mal placé on va faire cavalier f5
et chaque et on va venir s'en prendre
aux pions f6
comme l'elysée 1 c'est pas forcément la
manière la plus propre de gagner mais ça
va ça va le faire donc on va faire ça va
les prendre avec cette reprise alors ici
on peut prendre ici là il faut que je me
concentre un petit peu on peut prendre
ici il prend ici on prend du plomb et on
me laissera dame g7 maths c'est pas mal
on peut prendre un f6 il prend et on
joue cavalier des deux jouables aussi on
va prendre cette plus tôt
quoique fou prend des 3 puis enfin m6
bon
on va prendre le set et s'il prend comme
ça on fera tout reprend m6 pour cette
tour eu six échecs crois bouger on
prendra ans la dame
ok il prend ba écoute on va réutiliser
cette même idée tout reprend m6 pour
faire tous réussissent et ça devrait
suffire
surtout prendre à des retraits des trucs
avec dams g7 russie 1 mais mon tour si
c'est vrai je sais pas quel moment j'ai
pas été hyper propres ici je pense qu'on
aurait dû juste prendre un f6 on va
faire un échec
je
on va vraiment 8 une nouvelle fois sur
échec
et on va mettre le cavalier en d2
on va te faire qui menacent tour g8 on
va faire d'un match 4 on va espérer
qu'ils viennent en 17 pour lui coller un
petit road à mach 3 voilà la petite
double attaque donc ça aussi un les
erreurs classiques à votre niveau pièces
non protégés et ont réussi à lui prendre
son fou roi h1 et on va échanger les
pièces comme tout à l'heure maintenant
voilà on va mettre de la tourangelle
on menace maintenant une nouvelle fois
damage cette tour prend g8 donc toujours
les double attaque
voilà donc on échange
c'est tout bénef pour nous les échanges
ont remis leur ont h1 et aux menaces
toujours le damage cette dame prend h5
ok c'est pas un souci on va faire dame
f3 on va utiliser notre dame pour faire
des doubles attaque et gratter du matos
c'est l'objectif de prendre les pièces
non protégés là il ya un nouveau pion
qui va tomber et on va être complètement
gagnant bah on va plutôt faire de même
six échecs
double attaque pièces non protégés bon
évidemment il est cette menace mais il
en avait beaucoup
et la dame qui règne sur les chics
ok donc c'est gagner donc là pour vous
expliquer un peu le début de partie
donc le cadre des 5 5 si on fait fouet 5
un exemple des 4,6 qu'est ce qui se
passe on va avoir la position après e 4
e 6 d4 d5 peu cinq traits au noir donc
là avec les noirs on aurait eu très
envie de jouer fouet f5 puisque le fou
deux cases blanches c'est le grand
problème des noirs dans les françaises
donc ce fou est mal placé si on pouvait
le mettre en échec la ce serait une
bonne française d'ailleurs si vous voyez
il ya aussi eu quatre c6 des quatre des
cinq le 5-fu f5
on va jouer e6 et on va jouer une car
aucune variante d'avançon voudra jouer
ses 6 puis c'est 5% prendre au centre
donc ces deux variantes dans lesquels on
aurait là une position améliorée avec
les noirs puisque après fouet f 5 e 6 on
pourrait se permettre de jouer ces cinq
en un seul coup donc je serai une bonne
karo kann davance pour les noirs après
ce qu'a fait maths à faire c'est très
mauvais parce que sur 5 il a joué 2 6 on
a joué des quatre il a joué cavalier c6
donc là après dessins que si c'est pas
très grave parce qu'on rentre dans une
variante davance de la scandinave
peut-être commencer par cavalli ses six
buts varende avance de la française
pardon donc c'est peut-être pas grave
inséparables lors de couches que ces
faits qui sait si ceux ci soient aussi
direct mais qu'avaient laissé si si si
grosse erreur puisque dans la française
normalement on joue ces cinq pour s'en
prendre au centre et après on fait
cavalier c6 on attaque le centre dame b
si son attaque le pion et on va essayer
d'amener ce cavalier vers f5 pour s'en
prendre aux pions des 4 mai avec le coup
cavalli c6 les noirs peuvent plus
vraiment contester le centre blanc alors
après c'est pas si simple que ça a gagné
et même moi je ne vais pas jouer de
manière parfaite en voulant trop
expliqué mais voilà un peu ce qui s'est
passé dans cette partie et le truc qui
intéresse envoyez c'est qu'à ce niveau
donc 1400 on a fait un changement de
structure de pions c'est à dire qu'on a
on a commencé par une scandinaves on est
rentré dans une française mata faire je
sais qui c'est qu'il faut jouer ces cinq
dans cette position mais comme on a une
transposition c'est qu'on est parti
d'une ouverture on est arrivé à une
autre il s'est pas ajusté
il n'a pas fait l'ajustement pour pour
bien jouer cette position et donc il a
fait l'erreur
il a fait l'erreur de faire cavalier c6
pourquoi j'espère telle excuse action
vous a plu chez pas comme d'habitude
j'explique pas comme ça n'hésitez pas à
écrire dans le tchat ce que vous en avez
si vous aimez bien ou pas et moi je vais
essayer de mettre mes lunettes en
attendant été trouvé sur tous et bien
voilà il était là donc oui je sais pas
si ça vous plaît dans les commentaires
comme ça bien expliqué c'est un peu un
style différent
la partie était pas méga réussi de ma
part j'ai voulu gagner d'une manière et
léger pas et j'ai pas réussi à
j'ai voulu gagner juste en l'étouffant
pour vous montrer qu'on pouvait toucher
à rien mais mais j'aurais dû prendre en
russe en effet 6 un moment donné et
jouer sur la case 5 qui était faible
l'absurde probablement ici après cavale
et ashes y aurait dû prendre il est
obligé de reprendre du fou et j'aurais
pu jouer avec rock sur la case de 5 et
en tue elle demande permettant le
cavagnan lot 5 après ça aurait été
beaucoup plus propre bon allez on va
prendre des nouveaux défis
je vais mettre mes lunettes et on va
prendre
allez on va prendre les ocz est ce une
partie de trois minutes
on va jouer le 4 une nouvelle fois
5 allez on va faire cavaler à 3 va
utiliser le répertoire on va jouer
l'écossaise car lycées 6 des cartes
comme je vous disais l'objectif quand je
joue contre des joueurs de ce niveau là
et c'est pour ça que j'ai eu un petit
peu de mal dans la partie ii des feux de
la partie précédente partant à conclure
c'est que je vais essayer de pas trop
volontairement utilisé mes capacités
tactiques
parce que je comprends que vous aurez
beaucoup de mal à je veux pas me mettre
comme un espèce de très bons joueurs
parce que je le suis pas mais c'est sûr
ce sera difficile pour vous d'obtenir
des d'atteindre mon niveau en tactique
et en calcul c'est pas évident parce que
j'ai commencé petit et donc mon objectif
c'est de jouer tranquillement sans
essayer de faire mal sur la tactique et
de se concentrer sur la stratégie et sur
des choses que vous pourrez reproduire
dans vos parties
donc ici une joue des six il défend le
pion au 5 mai ce qui se passe c'est que
si on échange massivement sur re5 vous
allez le voir puis on prend puis on
prend et dame prend des 8
il sera obligée soit de reprendre du
cavalier et y perdra le pion aux 5 soit
du roi et il sera des rockets donc on va
jouer cette finale prise prise prises et
roy prend alors on va commencer par
mettre le cavalier en c3 parce que c'est
un coup qu'on aura besoin de jouer on
aurait pu aussi commencé par pousser 4
mais on veut voir un peu comment il se
développe peut-être fou c4 était mon
pouce et cat et jouable aussi comment il
joue au fc 6 donc il se garde une casse
pour le roi c'est tout à fait jouable et
maintenant votre employé un plan
intéressant
on va jouer le coup fous ces quatre donc
sur fouet 6
on prendra aussi c'est on créera des
pions doublé au centre alors c'est pas
si grave grave dans ses positions là
mais quand même c'est une concession et
s'ils jouent avec 6 on va s'en prendre à
lui paraître 4 alors l'idée de f4 ce
sera de provoquer la prise du pion alors
vous allez me dire ouais mais kevin tu
vas voir un pion isolé henri iv c'est
vrai mais après fou prend f4 jurés trois
pièces développer mon vous contrôlerez
la case c7 et je pourrai enchaîner par
grand roque sur échec avec le roi des 8
de notre ami noël chef qui sera en
grande difficulté donc il a fait six f4
donc on va un petit peu enchaîner les
coups et on a on a cette menace donc il
joue food & cie ce qui est à mon avis
assez bien joué
alors là son idée c'est que si
je prends il veut reprendre du fou et je
pourrai plus installer mon fou en f4
donc c'est un assez bon coup c'est bien
joué
si on fait petit rock il va prendre on
va jouer g3 alors pourquoi j'ai trois
parce que comme ça si prend ici je veux
reprendre du pillon et avoir nom sans
trait mon idée ça va être de mettre mon
fou en 2/3 de roke est de doubler
tranquillement les tours sur la colonne
sur la colonne des pardons et si je vous
fous j'ai quatre peut-être je serais
tenté un moment donné de jouer avec f5
et après h3g 4 et chasser le fouet et
faire une expansion à l'aileron f5
auraient tout à fait été jouée avec la
place de g3 mais j'ai envie de garder
mon centre est de voir comment il réagit
il pousse le pion donc mon fou doit
prendre une décision alors
on va faire quoi on peut reculer le fou
en d3 en e2
alors je vais le mettre en alors j'ai eu
deux des trois ou b 3 je vais le mettre
en b3 parce que je veux pas laisser son
souvenir en russie ce pour le moment ok
il fait à saint qui fait une expansion
va jouer à 4 l'idée c'est qu'on va
laisser pousser en b 4 et on va
redéployer notre cavalier vers la case
c4 alors on va passer par des uns ou par
ben alors on va passer plutôt par des 1
il va falloir qu'on protège ce pion et
après qu'on vienne à 3 et ont annoncé
quatre ce sera pas mal parce que quand
on vient d'en haut le 3é l'allemand
pourra manger en f4 qu'on pourra venir
en c4 on attaquera le fou et on pourra
re manger en f4 donc le joueur noir qui
se défend pas mal contre notre plan ok
donc sur kei c4 il aurait fou prend ses
quatre on va faire cavalier ou 3 quand
même et sur pions prend jouera cavaliers
f5 qui sera aussi très sympa tosh
puisqu'on s'en prendre à un peu aux
pions g7 on s'en prendra aux fous et
donc on sera pas mal quand il défend la
case f5 on va venir avec le cavalier en
c4 qu'on va s'en prendre aux fous sur
fou prend on jouera fou prend et on aura
gagné la paire de fou et maintenant
fouet trois on a obtenu l' avantage
alors je vais pas faire grande cuvée
carrément laissé le roi eux deux il est
mieux placé parce que je peux l'amener
un jour en f3 pour protéger les pions
autour des 1 il va jouer cavalier c6 et
on va colmater la case des quatre avec
le coup ces trois et vous voyez on n'a
pas de faiblesse on a gardé ce pion en
c3 exprès pour pour ne pas se faire pour
ne pas se faire rentrer dedans tour d2
c'est au cas où il fasse plus on prend
qui on prend c'est ce qui est en train
d'être joué qui n'est pas le coutour b2
donc il va mettre la tour en baisse est
maintenant on peut doubler nos tours sur
la colonne des et on va mettre le fou en
dessin qui du coup
ou en bep 500 des 5 ou en bessin qu'il
deux paraissent bien les deux paraissent
très bien les deux paraissent très bien
on va les en bessin qui on va garder la
case des 5 pour une autre tour qu'on
utilise la casse faible bon il est tombé
mais on avait on était en train de
dominer la partie on avait dominé
stratégiquement le milieu des allées on
va jouer contre un joueur un peu plus
fort on va jouer contre freud donc 1882
donc on va voir comment se débrouillent
freux 34
cette charte qui nous écrit ce couac est
pour kevin merci pour les explications
c'est bien sympa et pour une fois
inutile de se faire la traduction en
interne ouais on essaie de ne pas aller
trop vite donc c'est pas c'est plus dur
en terme de niveau de jeu sont essayé
d'aller doucement et de jouer des trucs
tranquille mais c'est quand même
efficace
quand jacques monsieur prendre
l'ouverture kim crush a reproposé une
partie sinon on va prendre une partie de
quelqu'un d'autre
elle va prendre christian lopez alors
non n'a pas réussi à le prendre à
prendre spirou joueur allemand le 4
alors on va jouer cinq on va jouer des
ouvertures que je joue pas trop on va
essayer de de jouer pour le centre on va
essayer de jouer à l'avant plus c'est
cool parce que je n'ai pas vraiment de
connaissances théoriques alors fou b5
bon on va jouer alors on va jouer un
truc un peu insipide on va jouer
cavalier j'ai eu 7
on va protéger le cavalier qui protège
le pion pour fait rien de très compliqué
pour le moment on va mettre le pion
angers 6 on va faire un petit chantier
taux pour contrôler le centre
je crois que c'est une petite bande qui
existe à moitié mais je connais pas trop
comment ça se joue puis on prend imagine
qui va reprendre et on va mettre le four
angers7
donc les blancs un meilleur contrôle du
centre ce qu'ils ont le pion en 4 qui
est bien placé et on peut pas vraiment
joué des cinq passes qui auraient pu on
prend est ce qu'on peut faire cavalier
prend il reprend du cavalier on reprend
ils prennent en c6 on reprend ils
prennent des 5
on reprend il vous faut c'est ici son
mail à tour en b 8 il vous faut prendre
des cinq et on prend b2 alors je sais
pas si ça marche on va le voir ensemble
non j'ai dit que je voulais ne pas
calculer mais c'est pas toujours facile
alors pourquoi des cinq il ya quand même
une idée stratégique derrière c'est
parce que vous voyez à ce pion en d4 qui
est mieux placé je peux très bien jouer
des 6es la jouer tranquillement avec le
pion des six mais il aura un avantage du
à son pion central ans le 4 et comme on
essaye de faire des trucs assez basique
aujourd'hui est assez sur le contrôle du
centre et les idées logique on essaye de
mettre le pion en d5 pour contrer donc
il prend ses 6 et on va se servir de ça
pour faire b prend donc on ramène un
pion vers le centre qui va nous
permettre de conserver le puant des cinq
sont fourbes et 5 est attaqué ça veut
dire que ça va être à lui de jouer va
être obligé de bouger le fou et je vous
laisse réfléchir pour trouver au coup
d'après comment on va jouer avec les
noirs
donc pour remporter une partie assez
facile en dix coups sans connaître la
théorie quasiment sur l'espagnol donc
après le coup de foudre importe lequel
quelques courriers vous avec les noirs
telle est ma question je vous laisse y
répondre
des quatre exactement exactement max
roche et bobby fischer la partie est
déjà terminée donc une victoire on dit
que vous voyez on n'a pas alors là
évidemment on a un petit peu de chance
je peux pas vous dire que battre dès
1900 sur trois points comme c'est aussi
facile que ça à chaque fois mais vous
voyez comment on peut avoir obtenir une
position gagnante très rapidement leur
après ce qu'on la gagnera ou pas c'est
autre chose mais mais on est très très
bien donc là j'ai envie de mettre le
cavaliere le 7 pourront s'en prendre aux
pions des 5
on mettra la tour en huit aussi pour
éviter un peu les clous âge à la foux c5
le fou en b 7 on va essayer de taper le
pion tout en douceur alors j'ai pas très
envie de faire fou prend ces trois cas
il prend des 5 même si sa gagnant de
médecins l'important armes vous voyez
que quand quand on applique des
principes clairs qu'on a des idées qu'on
sait ce qu'on fait on peut faire des
choses pas pas mal du tout donc tour
huit ans enlève du cloud âge c'est ce
que je vous disais juste avant tout re
on va mettre le fou en bessette et on va
s'en prendre directement à ce pion des
cinq c'est le point faible des blancs et
on est en supériorité numérique on a une
pièce de plus donc il va échanger des
pièces mais comme vous le savez les
échanges quand on a un avantage matériel
on est pour donc la foux prend des six
nous qu'est-ce qu'on fait cavalier f5
on attaque le fou et on va provoquer des
échanges
automatiquement il est obligé des
changes et donc il veut pas échangé des
dames ils échangent les tours mais
qu'est ce qui se passe maintenant madame
elle est super bien placé
le fou toujours attaqué et on va
commencer à pouvoir lui poser des
problèmes
alors on va commencer peut-être pas
retour des 8 pour développer on mettra
la dame ans et 6 après ça permet de
développer sur tempo temps que ses
protégés si la dame des anges et 4 on
s'en servira pour lui mettre un petit
coup de hache cinq îles mais la dame en
f1 pourquoi pas et j'ai quand même envie
d'amener la dame ans et 6 parce que même
si le maté protégeant g2 une petite
batterie ça fait pas de mal
alors là un coup comme fou prend ces
trois serait aussi très bon
ok on va ramener le cavalier en d4
on va menacer cavaliers français 2
il ya j'aurais jamais de problème de
clouage impasse que ses protégés en plus
on peut même revenir vers eu 6 après
pour colmater des cases mais en fait
pour tout vous dire je veux pas voulu
cacher je veux faire cavalier acte iii
qui comprend f3 alors là ça marche pas
mais je veux faire cavaler puisque yari
à la tour derrière mais je veux faire un
truc avec cavaliers pros f3 tu en prends
f3 d'un point f3 pour aller le maté à la
brutale mais là je menace lui puisqu'il
ya plus à tour en vain mais on menace
cavaliers français deux tours 8 c'est
pour sortir du clonage et en menace qui
est français deux cavaliers prend ces
deux qu'on va jouer d'ailleurs
donc on gagne un pion et surtout prend à
on va on va jouer une jolie tactique sur
vous prend à 7 je vais vous laisser ses
recherchés
allez on a les noirs on peut regagner
encore du matériel ici de manière forcée
et c'est à vous de ça vous de chercher
comment gagner du matériel ici avec les
noirs de manière forcée
comment faire allez c'est à vous de
jouer
il faut trouver
allez on réfléchit et on trouve en niqab
a lieu un nom sur ke relief trois tours
8 heures la tour et des gens 1,8
j'imagine que tu nies tourer mais le
problème surtout on sait qu'il va faire
tout reprendre un cavalier provins il
n'est pas obligé de me manger
il peut faire f3 allez on réfléchit les
mecs cave a lieu un pareil va faire f3
allé comme on gagne du matériel de
manière forcée ici vous prend cavaliers
mon gagne qu'un pion tour des huit
il ya tout reprend des huit matchs allez
les mecs un petit effort quand même
voilà c'est de la tactique est à 2
balles france et 3 sagan qu'un pion à
l'est on veut gagner plus gros comment
est-ce que ce soit moi qui soit aveugle
mais moi je gagne voilà x 6
merci sur le vif ex donc ça c'est des
petits c'est du petit jeu tactique qu'il
faut voir les mecs voyez brac en avant
avant le fou prend à cette je l'avais
déjà le x 6 à leur goût comme je disais
j'ai plus de vitesse de calcul que vous
et où et quand même c'est le genre de
petit qu'il faut voir la dame est en f1
elle est mal placée elle peut être
enfermé fois ci sont semées dans la
diagonale ont fait mal fouetter pas
enfermé il pourrait revenir
voilà une partie propre fois ci c'est
une partie très probablement un petit
peu revenir alors on va revenir alors
avec ce moment des singles relate la
baronne qui nous posait un peu question
s'était prise prise est ici ici avec pas
mal de trucs à faire pour les blancs
alors moi le premier truc que j'ai vu
c'était prise crise prises alors là
j'aurais peut-être pu prendre même en b5
d'ailleurs à ce moment là mais ça ça
devrait aller il ya le fou qui va
briller et sur pions prende à me prend
sa vente que j'avais vu de base mais
avait des d'autres coûts qui était
jouable fous ces six tours b mythe et là
j'avais raté fou c'est 100 kg 1
peut-être qu'ils attaquent et la tour et
surtour des huit fawcett est peut-être
des variantes comme ça après avoir ainsi
un peu il ya encore il ya encore
peut-être des choses à faire mais mes
surprises prise prise là y'avait dame
prend des cinq qui paraissait bien car
il sait 3h oui c'est ça donc ça ça
allait mais la question qu'on pouvait se
poser c'est est prise prise est prise en
c6 ça c'était peut-être c'était
peut-être une bonne solution pour les
blancs puisque sûr qu'elle prend ces
trois épreuves dont dame prend des huit
qui gagne vous voyez dame prend des
limites prise est prise ou encore les
quais prend b5 et sajoo mais j'ai
l'impression que le cavalier on réussira
pas le gagner il sera protégé mais
toujours à voir mais peut-être qu'on
peut prendre
il prend on prend ici
ces gens comme ça qui était jouable la
dame fourest attaquez vous pouvez
prendre la tourbe et 8 et peut-être vous
prend à 7 des choses comme ça ça
peut-être qu'il avait quelque chose qui
gagnait de manière directe ça après
avoir mais bon comme je disais j'ai
essayé de jouer des cinq pour jouer de
manière logique sans vraiment trouver
comment les blancs pouvaient gagner il
fallait jouer de manière plus précise
avec les blancs il a fait une erreur
directe
donc voilà pour cette partie
alors on va jouer contre tetris 95e 4
alors on va rejouer aux 5
on va rejouer des parties de pion
central cavalière trois cavaliers c6
protège le pion des quatre une écossaise
puis on prend cavaliers prend on va
jouer à alors à jouer fou c'est ça qu'on
va s'en prendre à son cavalier on va
voir comment il réagit fouet 3 alors fou
et trois sur cavaillé hafsi simona skype
français 6 1 qui menacerait la dame ait
gagné le fou dame f6 l'idée c'est qu'on
attaque le cavalier sur cavaliers procès
si on va jouer d'armes français si ce
fou prend ses cinq dames français sont
donc là pied de la dame viendrait
protéger on va voir comment il réagit en
lay lay est une menace quand même en c3
on va jouer les cavaliers g en hausse
est donc développement des pièces fous
ces quatre on va rockets crocs et ici je
pense on va tenter cavalier e 5
je suis pas sûr que ce soit le bon coup
puisqu'il ya un truc à 4 4 mais bon
c'est pas du tout mon répertoire je veux
voir ce qu'ils allaient jouer
je connais pas trop trop mais camaïeu 5
fut pas sûr alors ok to b 3 on va mettre
le pion en d6 et j'imagine ici f4
cavaliers g4 et on va venir s'en prendre
aux fous au kef quatre cavaliers g car
tu pense qu'il aurait dû revenir en e2
et on menace le fouet trois ici et si le
four recul on aura du damage 4 ou
cavaliers c6 d'ailleurs pour s'en
prendre aux cavaliers donc là il a un
vrai problème avec son foin bon écoute
on est bien iliad se demande comment je
peux jouer contre toi ben il suffit de
le défier
alors f5 c'est un coup que je comprends
pas du tout cavalier prendre trois
fourchettes gagné une pièce difficile là
pour tetris 95
on va gagner dames 2 cavaliers pour un
f1 le cavalier des cats va rester en
prise on va s'en emparer alors on va pas
le prendre tout de suite on va carrément
faire payer ces six comme ça on le
prendra fin on aurait pu prendre prendre
et faire avant le rude à même de les
changer d'âme mais bon là du coup c'est
tout ce que je vois c'est que sur pied
des deux comprendra qu'il part avec le
roi on va prendre un an avec lecavalier
bon je vais pas forcément jouer de
manière idéale mais c'est pas évident
pour moi de rester très concentré avec
une tour de plus on va prendre le
cavalier pour pas laisser s'activer à
une cavale et dessins qui on va ramener
le fou en c6 on va s'en prendre aux
pions va ramener les tours 8,5 on va
pilonner le pion le 4 on va finir par le
gagner parce qu'on en avantages
matériels et on va encore augmenter
notre avantage
donc on devrait gagner
donc
fous ces six là c'est l'option de 4 et
comme je vous disais on va pilonner avec
nos tours ce pion arriérés cas où on
mettra la dame aux recettes et toutes
façons dans supériorité numérique donc
on est sûr de gagner ce pion ces salles
avantages que vous avez plus de matériel
aux échecs c'est que vous êtes sûrs
d'aller de gagner le pion faible peut
passer une défense pas possible c'est
mathématique
c'est mathématique ça joue tout seul on
pilonne
et on gagne donc il le défend mais le
truc c'est que rien truc marrant sexy
mph et j'ai quatre tours 8 pour me jouer
g5 et s'en prendre à madame et
m'attaquer j'aurais d'armes par f5 pour
jouer sur le clouage mais ce sera gagné
sur ce qu'il est en train de faire j'ai
senti qu'il voulait faire ça non alors
on n'y est pas encore
alors maintenant il faut qu'on gagne le
pion et on peut le gagner de deux
manières différentes on peut aussi je
veux gagner par des cinq donc ça c'est
aussi typique quand il ya un espèce de
20 pions isolé ou ou un pion arriérés
c2c de le gagner avec un pion alors là
c'est vrai que le truc c'est que du coup
j'ai pu dame prend f5 qui et quoi qu
est-ce que j'ai le beau jeu ou pas
est-ce que j'ai eu du beau jeu ou pas on
va essayer de réfléchir
bon ça ce serait le beau jeu mais en
partie je vous conseille vraiment pas de
le faire donc on va jouer on va jouer
normal on va jouer là d'amendés 6 / f6
de toute façon fera g6 et au cas où même
il viendrait en fils on avait toujours
d'un v8 pour défendre et au prochain
l'on va lui faire puis on prend 2,4
bonjour à la tour on échangera les damés
et ça va être fini
bonsoir brooks
comme j'ai dit j'espère que ça vous
plaît un c'est un peu différent de ce
qu'on fait d'habitude mais tourcoing f5
aussi jouable mais bon allez on va faire
puis on prend 1,4 année est aussi
tourcoing f5 oui comme on le signale
dans le chat pour jouer sur le clouage
aussi gagnant devant tout gagner mais je
vais faire le beau jeu avec dame prend
f5 mais c'était un peu compliqué ok
viens là on va pousser le pion 3 et là
encore je vais vous montrer un truc pour
pas se casser la tête il va faire rage
et 1 et on va mettre la dame en d2 avec
l'idée de jouer damev deux échecs pour
échanger les dames ce qui va nous
simplifier la vie
mais changer les dames dans une position
avec autant de matériel d'avant ça
facilite la vie donc on va essayer de le
faire et aux menaces d'heure le fou
c'est 2 1
au passage on the path pas ainsi manger
7 on peut manger ces deux en premier on
pourrait aussi manger sain qui mangent
des saints qui ont fait des progrès en
maths
bon ok il fait un sacrifice on prend il
fait un échec on vient là
et ça va pas plus loin à noter que sur
fou prend 1,7
s'il y avait eu quelque chose on aurait
toujours pu on aurait pas eu de roi et
fuite puis on prend vraiment réussi roi
et flic en g7 et crise mais bon prenez
le fouet il avait rien du tout donc mais
c'était pas mal tenté
allez on va jouer notre adversaire on va
essayer de prendre plutôt des parties
plus longue alors on va apprendre
exterminateurs 444 du canada alors il
fait 4 on va jouer cinq on va rester sur
le 4 5 cavaliers f3 cavaliers celle ci
s'en va continuer ce cette chose-là fou
c4 à l'âge du fer fou c5 et b4 donc là
on efface un gang ils veulent je connais
pas du tout
donc tu face à quelque chose qui est
potentiellement très dangereux et on va
voir comment s'en sort donc on va
remettre le fou en c5 c'est peut-être
très mauvais à vous connaissez peut-être
et vous dit peut-être c'est très beau
greffe ou c5 mon hockey des quatre tempo
je vais prendre
il va prendre et je vais revenir en d4
donc là c'est un peu la mauvaise
nouvelle on se retrouve contre quelque
chose qu'on connaît pas et qui est
dangereux alors comment est-ce qu'on va
se débrouiller avec ça déjà on identifie
que c'est un peu chaud puisque si on
sort le cavalière et fils on va se
prendre de 5
donc ça c'est très mauvais maintenant
est-ce que l'on peut prendre en d2 et
sortir le cavalier vers h6 alors c'est
moche mais ça va permettre de protéger à
vii de faire rock tranquillement et dont
on a toujours un pion de plus maintenant
la question qu'on se pose c'est ce
qu'ont fait cavaler agissent direct et
on laisse fou prend des quatre cavaliers
prend des quatre cavaliers mal placée
sur le bord où est ce que on commence
par fou prend des dehors j'ai envie de
commencer par vous prendrez 2 puisque je
me dis que la dame pourrait venir en b3
et seraient bien placés
alors il prend du cavalier pour le
moment il n'y a pas de menace blanche
direct donc j'ai envie de commencer par
des six sur fou prend pour le moment
giroix prend et y'a pas de problème
ok yves roques tempo maintenant la
grande question c'est est-ce que je sors
mon cavagnan f6 et je me prend 1,5
où est ce que je le sors différemment
j'ai peur de le sortir en deux sets
parce que j'ai peur de me prendre
cavaliers g5 petit rock et damages 5 et
on sait que c'est trois pièces
coordonner le fou la dame et le cavalier
c'est très dangereux c'est ce qu'on
appelle le mag de greco mai juin vous
complètement anti positionnelle je fais
cavaliers h6 je joue comme si j'avais
peur je passe un bon coup ou pas mais
comme si je voulais développer mes
pièces je veux pas calculer pour voir si
j'ai le temps de faire cavalier 7 et des
5 ou quoi je veux juste jouer de manière
très sécurisée sans vraiment utiliser de
calcul mais donc je reste avec mon pion
de plus et je me dis finalement bomba
les blancs ils ont un petit peu de ils
ont eu un peu d'attac ce cavalier en
artiste c'est vrai qu'il est mal placé
mais il défend le pion à vii
finalement il a une utilité et moi mon
idée maintenant c'est de faire cavalier
à 5 et cavaliers français 4 1 quand même
c'est d'aller récupérer le fou c4
donc cavalier à 5 c'est bien joué on va
s'en prendre au fouet à la dame est
comme ça on va récupérer ce fou de cases
blanches qui est fort et finalement ce
gang evans
il n'aura pas apporté grand chose après
je suis pas du tout serein je la bonne
part d'entre eux comme je ne connais pas
la théorie mais vous non plus vous ne
connaissez pas la théorie donc quelque
part c'est intéressant alors question
est ce qu'on a le temps de caler ses
cinq intermédiaire prise prise d'armes
français cinq escales à ce moment là
quand il me fait d'armes français 5
j'ai un coup intéressant j'ai pas
l'impression
donc je vais prendre en c4 avec plaisir
maintenant mon problème c'est mon
cavalier h si c'est une pièce qui est
très mal placé donc j'ai plusieurs
problèmes et je m'en fous ces mythes qui
n'est pas développé et j'ai mon cavalier
qui est sur le bord alors on va
commencer déjà par fou au cices on va
développer sur tempo
s'ils jouent des 5 il poussera les bleus
pions voilà et ça va me donner de
l'espace pour mes pièces alors je vais
mettre le feu ont 17 et ça veut dire qu
éventuellement je pourrais mettre ce
cavalier angers 4 et ont eu cinq
voiliers cette belle case 2,5 s'est
libéré et s'ils jouent au sein qui se
passe pas forcément grand chose
il attaque mon pioncer donc je vais le
défendre alors je pourrais aussi jouer
ses 5,1 d'ailleurs mais bon va le
défendre pour le moment j'attends la
jouer tranquille
ensuite on essaie de jouer kg 4e 5 on va
replacer le cavalier vers le centre
on souffre encore un petit peu
on souffre encore un poil
enfin souffre on est bien mais leurs six
feux 5 on pourra faire prise prises et
peut-être amené le cavalier vers des six
il s'en prend aux pions écoutez le pion
on va le défendre
on va faire b6 comme ça en mai les pions
sur noir et le fou sur blanc et on va
peut-être ci-après de fer à 5 pour
commencer notre expansion à l'ale dames
bon on va prendre écouter il va
reprendre 20 escales vaillant g4 parce
que ce cavalier ça fait un moment qu'il
est très mal placée sur le bord et on va
utiliser cette occasion pour le
développer pour le re développer au pire
on échangera fou contre contre cavaliers
mais on est content parce que ce
cavalier c'était notre moins bonnes
pièces depuis un moment voilà et on s'en
débarrasse
et on s'en débarrasse alors maintenant
il fait d'alger 3 il menace le fou g4
mais on va servir d'un petit subterfuge
tactique on voit que la pièce en d2
n'est pas protégé on va jouer dame temps
des 5 avec l'idée de regagner le
cavalier en d2 au prochain coup comme ça
s'il fait d'armes franges et ce quatre
confrères dame prend des deux et on aura
échanger encore du matériel on restera
avec nos deux pions de plus
ok juste un truc un peu dangereux
d'ailleurs que j'avais pas calculé de
base c'était cavalier e 4 qui pouvait
faire un peu peur parce que si on bouge
le fouille avec avaya f 6 mai sur
cavalier e 4 j'aurais probablement
répondu f5 qui me permettait de protéger
le fouet de couvrir la casaque six dons
qu'il a pris on va prendre nous mêmes en
d2 on menace dame prend 1,2 quand même
encore un pion est ce qu'on voudrait
jouer au prochain j'imagine cc cinq pour
simplement protéger le pion c'est on va
créer une nouvelle chaîne de pions et en
voyant qu'ils ont passé
kerry fedama 4 donc qui menace le pion à
il protège le son pion à
écoute on va le défendre en avançant de
cases et là notre prochain coup si on
pouvait jouer je pense ce serait d'am
dam b4 alors c'est pas tout à fait
simple encore parce qu'il a un peu de un
peu d'activité donc d'un beckham c'est
logique on enlève la dame et aux menaces
enfin veut échanger l'adoption de plus
on veut échanger sur dame 17 on fera un
petit coup prophylactique 2 h 6 qui
mangera pas de pain ok donc ça c'est
grosse erreur des blancs je pense parce
qu'il vient rentrer dans cette finale où
il a finalement deux pions - je pense
fallait absolument qui tente à 3 alors
là il ya plusieurs écoles pour la gagner
on peut essayer de faire tours à huit
tours des six tours prend tout reprend
bon mais si on met une tour ans et lui
souhaite pas si simple
écoutez ce qu'on va faire ce qu'on veut
jouer tour des huit on va proposer les
échanges des tours on va jouer on va
mettre le rang avec 8 on va ramener
notre roi au centre on va centraliser
nos trois c'est important on va éviter
par la même occasion les maths du
couloir et maintenant on va faire tout
reprendre et on aurait pu dire le joue
beaucoup d'avant mais je voulais pas me
prendre pour des six mois à refaire tout
reprendre un tour prenait un roi hausse
est donc le roi vient colmater la 6e
ranger et maintenant tour à 8 pour venir
en a 3 coupé le roi adverse qui peut me
mettre des échecs
ça ne me dérange absolument pas donc là
il veut vouloir trouver le contre je
mais le problème c'est que l'option b
pas de contre je c'est malin ce qu'a
voulu faire exterminator il n'a pas
voulu jouer passif il a voulu jouer le
contre eux je mets le problème quand tu
me contre eux je sais que si
l'adversaire est une case de dames pas
de casse de dams et c'est dur c'est dur
maintenant on va finir en douceur un
échec centralise la dame et on va faire
comme au ping pong au billard on va lui
choper la la tour sur watch 2 je voulais
faire de la m quatre échecs et lui
choper la tour bon
j'espère une nouvelle fois que ça vous
intéresse formats très différents de ce
qu'on fait d'habitude je sais pas si ça
vous êtes vraiment à progresser ou quoi
j'essaie d'expliquer très lentement des
concepts simples alors on joue contre
joue tuer ce qui nous vient du pays
basque j'imagine et ouais c'est le pays
basque donc que 4 des gens aiment bien
qu'on réussisse d4 d5 et e5 halle
d'arles d'apt attendre des trucs très
simple ces cinq c3 donc on maintient
notre centre envie d'amener six
cavaliers f3 écoutez je vais pas faire
quoi que ce soit de très compliqué
normalement j'aurais fou détroit et en
gambie leur mari mais je vais je vais
faire comme si je jouais une mauvaise
variante je jouais food mais c'est juste
de faire de la stratégie donc là
normalement avec les noirs on va essayer
de jouer quelque chose comme cavalier
sept cavaliers f5 et sur quoi je
répondrai cavaliers à 3 cavalia 2 jouer
une position complètement insipide et
pas pas essayer de prendre l'aventage
sur l'ouverture
ok donc là cavalier à 6,6 venir sur f5
j'ai quand même très envie de le prendre
pas du tout envie de laisser arrivé ici
j'ai envie de m'en débarrasser
je pense que sur dame prend b2 jeu
devant fermer la dame je sais pas après
je suis pas sûr je pense que oui mais je
suis pas sûr je pense que sur dame prend
b2
j'aurais fait j'aurais hésité mais
peut-être quelque chose comme fou des
deux dames ces deux pour bloquer la dame
et contrôler la case des quatre avec le
fou et avec l'idée de préparer rock et
cavaliers c3 je pense quelque chose
comme ça pour gagner là la dame avec la
torah donc il a pris en réussissent avec
le pion maintenant ils menacent ce pion
là bon je vais mettre la dame en d2 je
vais protéger mon pions et sur pied on
prend qui on prend fou b4g évidemment le
cavalier qui va venir en c3 donc au
prochain coup c'est rock et madame en d2
elle tape aussi un peu en affinitaire
qu'un jour je peux prendre à fils de
venir jouer cet été attaqué
rachid un premier de marche possible
comme je dis je des ventes que je ne
connais pas et jouent pas des bandes
très bonne ok maintenant que fait-on
alors à mettre le cac gagnant à a3 ces
ajouts et b5 et b6
tu crois qu'on va reprendre
on va essayer de mètres carrés en bessin
quelques années un an 10,6
un autre plan ça pourrait donner le
cavalier ans et 2,3 g 4 ok donc le
joueur noir qui veut détruire le centre
pourquoi pas c'est pas mal joué de sa
part
un f6 hockey
et j'ai un frère avec ce cavalier ce
cavalier il va ici alors pour aller ici
il faut passer par là pour venir ici en
bessin que ça peut pas être bon parce
qu'on est en diagonale b1 non plus ça
veut dire qu'il faut passer par ces deux
pour venir en c2 faut jouer b3 donc le
plein alors je sais pas si on va avoir
le temps de le faire un message de faire
ça ça ça et ça ça m'a l'air assez long
et difficile mais on va voir comment un
joueur de ce niveau varie pour nous on
va commencer par b3 on va espérer qu'ils
aient pas de tactique aurait peut-être
des des trucs et des détours pour un f3
prisé sacrifice de carlos tous les trucs
comme ça mais on va essayer de voir ce
qu'il va faire on va juste mettre un
plan en place on va dire qu'on calcule
pas trop de tactique et on va mettre un
plan en place
juste mettre le plan en place on va voir
comment il répond à ce plan donc le plan
est simple on veut venir ici ici et ici
et en plus quand on prend ici on a eu
droit on aura le gros point positif
qu'on s'en prendra aux pions des 5
après tour par les froisser 30 ans quand
même pour les noirs même on va voir
comment il joue
alors les amis comment est-ce que jon
chu h
j'en joue à cheval alors on va mettre le
cavalier en c2 on va mettre notre plan
plaçant remettre le cavalier ici ici et
ici
alors il veut ramener le fou en h5
probablement la rigueur on va laisser
faire peut pas tout empêcher
c'est vrai qu'il m'a empêché al qaïda
arrivant j'ai 4 mais bon cavalier pas si
mal placée en eux trois bien que le
fongecif bon écoute on va mettre notre
plan en place mais on est quand même
très mal
c'est le français ce qui s'est mal passé
donc voyez là on n'a pas voulu utiliser
de connaissances théoriques du tout je
veux une warndt que je savais plus ou
moins mauvaise avec le font à eux deux
et au final on se retrouve moins bien
contre un joueur classé 14 130 pour ça
on a dans certaines parties des
connaissances théoriques ont été
inutiles à dans celle là ça va nous
manquer bon j'aurais dû jouer tg4
qu'avant puisqu'il est pas tous rêvent 4
une partie que je vois assez mal parce
que j'avais vu sur kg 4 tours f4 ok
maintenant il sacrifie la qualité donc
pourquoi ne l'a pas at-il fait plus tôt
alors on va
il joue il joue vraiment pas mal ce
joueur il joue vraiment pas mal
on est vraiment assez mal je pense on va
remettre le font eux deux
en gagner ces deux matches on est un peu
long
qui
ça va c'est mon style de qualité ou qui
a pu mettre un plan en place assez
basique h5 ok bon on va revenir en e3
tranquillement est ce vraiment réussir à
nous faire mal h 4 on va mettre le front
g4 comme ça le fond j'ai cathy va
colmater un petit peu les cases blanches
autour du roi et ça va m'enlever les
problèmes de cavaliers eu deux échecs en
tout cas momentanément
là on est parti vraiment dur donc je
vous conseille sur la française peut
faire le gambit miller barry ou variante
des changes
peut-être plus simple leur foi je 3bet
laurent achard on va essayer de pousser
f4 prendre de l'espace f 5 après ouvrir
les lignes c'est ce qu'il faut faire on
va enlever le roi de ce vis-à-vis
on va se barrer en h1 et on va envoyer
des pions vous voyez le pion f
bon je vais enlever le roi ça évitera se
prendre un jour une un problème
genre un cavalier c2 qui éprouvent 3
puis on prend 1,3 fou prend 1,3 ya plus
d'échecs bien de s'enlever des clous âge
auquel outil on va laisser on va laisser
changer en a eu trois gagnées du
matériel comme ça on va ça va nous
permettre d'échanger des tours et
d'ouvrir les lignes il y aura le pion
aux 600 en ligne de mire c'est pour ça
qu'une urbain avec la dame tout comme ça
je visage 4 éventuellement je vis depuis
envoyé vise le pion h 4 vise le pion aux
six sages et deux options et s'y prend
que je prends de la dame ici c'est pas
grave et je pourrais monter à la volée
avec ma tour s'y prendre la dame
je ferai toujours un voilà c'est
exactement ça et vous voyez l'utilité
alors il est tombé c'est dommage je
voyais et l'utilité de laisser le pion
c'est que ça permet d'ouvrir les lignes
et quand les lignes s'ouvre qui sait qui
parle c'est la tour c'est tonton tour e
c'est tonton les tours les fous se
limite vraiment envoyé dans cette
position là quand la position était
encore assez fermé c'étaient les pièces
mineurs qui jouait beaucoup et tout d'un
coup là quand la pièce la position s'est
ouverte et tout d'un coup on sent que
les tours les fous et les dames commence
à briller sur l'échiquier le sait une
partie plus difficile un seul a été plus
difficile
alors on va jouer contre elle va prendre
elliott cas partie en dix minutes
alors 4 on va continuer avec eux cinq
cavalière trois cavaliers ces six pouces
et quatre pouces et 5 en espérant qu'on
va pas reprendre gambie evans un peu la
cata dans le dernier
et si tout le monde fait de gambier
veulent donc je vous recommande de
l'étudier malgré ces fois cette fois ci
dk l'on va suivre la même logique
je veux faire coucher et cinq noms maroc
bon ok c'est vraiment dangereux ce qu'en
dit
ok on va comment on va jouer ce cas du
coup joué avec avaya h6 comme tout à
l'heure c'est plus compliqué parce qu'il
peut leur [ __ ]
dans ces pays n'ont qu'à faire des six
mais j'aime pas trop
sur peut-être dû jouer des trois avec le
recul
ben kay menace on va défendre
dangereux ce derby dangereux sur flu g5
f6 où pranger 8 normalement encore fait
engranger 5
on s'en sort mais on est très mal là on
est très très mal
je pense que ça va ça va être la partie
de trop moi je vais mettre le fou en b 6
je pense que cela va être la partie ou
peut-être vraiment on va souffrir dans
quoi est faite attention un cancan vous
quand vous jouez des ouvertures vraiment
à prendre les gants guy dangereux pour
savoir comment les réfuter ou moins
comment jouer contre eux s'ils sont pas
réfutable parce que sinon c'est vraiment
ce qui attrait dangereux de plan b et c
est un peu tout défendre et puis de
toute heure c'est que sur calais 5 je
vais sortir mon cavalier h6 pour
défendre et maintenant j'ai ramené le
fourbe et 6 pour 1 pour un truc simple
c'est que je veux protéger couvrir mon
pions bessette et développer
éventuellement mon fou verger 4 ça me
permettra de revenir au cas le cas
échéant verger 6 alors la foulée 5 c'est
un coup que je trouve assez faible
peut-être je vois pas l'idée mais il
sort de cette pression sur la case 9,7
et il met une pression sur ses six duels
il a créé une menace il a créé une
menace en un coût qui est des cinq mais
cette menace je la part en faisant
quelque chose que j'avais envie de jouer
de toute façon maintenant il fait 5
pour ouvrir la position je vais prendre
une fois au 5 et quand il va reprendre 5
je reprendrai pas ce que je veux pas me
laisser ouvrir la colonne veut la ffu à
3 ça c'est bien jouer encore
je retire ce que j'ai dit c'est assez
bien joué parce que des cinq ça va être
sur fourchette j'aurais peut-être dû
jouer autre chose
damas ici sur eux ça ne fallait pas
prendre prendre devait être funéraire
faille sûrement faire grand roque direct
bon j'ai rien dit on est assez mal quand
même
va pas critiquer le jeu d'un travail
sérieux si fou b5 fuqua suis je suis
convaincu que c'est un mauvais coup mais
j'ai pas très bien réagi sur cinq il
poursuivait faire le grand direct et se
barrer bon position qui reste complexe
sur puis on prend on va essayer de
partir vers g6 ouvert h6 je sais pas
encore il faut vraiment qu'on essaye de
vraiment grave et six à extirper le roi
du centre rapidement là
on va mettre la dame angeli 6 pour le
moment on va garder un oeil sur le pion
à vii ça me permettra de faire rock et
pas perdre de matériel c'est toujours
bien
comme vous avez très tranquille si on
réussit à faire grand roque quand même
ça devrait aller devrait passer juste
juste mais ça devrait passé ric-rac en
panique pas on défend tous cavale et c3
et on va faire grand roque
ça reste compliqué parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de pièces sur le roi et même si
on a rockets ça reste dangereux j'ai
peur d'un coup comme cavalier des 5 par
exemple il va m'empêcher un peu de jouer
cavalier 7 et il va vouloir me prendre
prendrai peut-être faire un jeu sur la
colonne à ça peut être dangereux
ça peut être très dangereux c'est ce
qu'ils jouent derrière d'ailleurs
du coup on va être le roi en b 8 en semi
anticipation de ce truc permettra de
colmater un peu la colonne avec le roi
et aussi sur cavaliers à 5 maintenant il
y aura plus vous prendrez cet échec vous
prend 17 sera plus sûr échec
donc il prend va reprendre
ça reste du rhin mais on survit tant
bien que mal
alors on a un auditeur qui maîtrise à
lui j'ai découvert ce serait en français
y'a pas longtemps je regardais surtout
les stream d'échec en anglais tu
expliques beaucoup c'est souvent très
intéressant il ya un planning prévu à
l'avancé pour l'estrie marois et d'un
stream tous les jeudis à 20h donc c'est
le stream du jeudi est a aussi un stream
pour les arénas king que les mercredis
soirs alors là on explique moi d'en
faire gaffe un fou prend cavaliers prend
fou prend tout reprend il vient mettre
la pression
il veut menacer fou prend cavaliers
prend mais là on va mettre le cavalier
en des cinq mois là on commence à
s'activer
c'est pas le feu encore
sur tmc katché pas trop quoi faire
peut-être cavalia 5 dame prend des 5
allez on va devoir a utilisé peut-être
un peu de calcul pour s'en sortir mais
je veux tenter cavaliers à cinq dames
des 5es fouache 3 il va faire cavaler h4
pour menacer madame je vais faire tout
reprendre et 5 gagné sa tour il fera
cavalier pranger 6 puis on prend g6 il
ya mon fou qui reste en prise mais à son
foie lui aussi donc on va faire cavalier
à 5 et le cavalier des cinq protège la
casse c'est celle donc sur dame prend
des 5 fu h3 j'aurais quand même cette
double attaque et je vois pas trop
qu'est-ce qu'il a d'autres que cavaler
h4 pour continuer là-dessus
on avait peut-être aussi fou aussi ce
qu'un coût possible
avec comme idée sur foot français six
cavaliers trois canadiens sur quatre et
prendre bon ok on va voir ça que ce que
ça donne donc je disais cavaliers h
quatre tours prend des cinq cavaliers
pranger 6h pranger 6 vous allez voir
c'est la variante qui va se dérouler
sous vos yeux
est ce que je vous disais c'est que ma
tour menace le fou et que même si ce fou
et emprises bah oui ça va faire un
échange et si le four recul on va
reculer notre fou les trucs très
importants avoirs c'était crous et 4
était pas possible à cause de calais
prend c4 parce que j'avais évidemment
dur quand j'ai calculé et donc
maintenant après tout reprend b5
on a toujours le pion de plus qu'on
avait gagné au début du gambit donc on a
pignon de plus et il ya h 3 et de 5 ans
prise donc on va avoir deux pions de
plus c'est une finale complètement
gagnante
mais notre adversaire a très bien joué
cette partie vraiment bravo à lui il
fait une bonne partie est donc
maintenant on va pouvoir encaisser ce
point à 1,5
et ça ça fait du bien je dis bien parce
que c'est ma meilleure structure de
pions et là cavalier c6 très important
on colmate c7 et on va pouvoir
maintenant organiser nos tour
tranquillement un peu s'en prendre à
ceux qui ont h
bon on va mettre une tour en eux deux
tours 2e
il va devoir mettre une tour en c2 et on
va jouer f6 et le truc qui sera pas mal
c'est qu'on aura la casse de cette
protégée par le cavalier le roi s'est
vite qui couvrira la 7e donc on va
prendre prendre à mettre le pion à m6 on
bloque l'action du fou et on va mettre
leur ont ensuite pour venir contrôler
cette case
maintenant bon là sinon j'aurais joué
autrement mais on va s'y donne un pion
va quand même le prendre
donc là ça nous fait ça commence à faire
des pions là ça fait trois pions va
mettre la tour en 1 h 5 et on va faire
trois décès trois là et on mettra tour
des 5 pour bloquer la colonne a une
nouvelle fois pas de souci tout écolo
ratez pas de case d'entrée
pas de case d'entrée
merci à elliott cas qui a fait une très
bonne partie alors qu'est ce qu'on va
prendre
allons apprendre du amine tv en 5 + 5
belle cadence le 5 + 5
mais voyons n'étais pas très bien dans
la position on a réussi à colmater tous
plus ou moins tant bien que mal on va
refaire ou cinq cavaliers f3 cavaliers
c6 temps va rester sur nos fondamentaux
des cartes ra apprenons des quatre
prisons va tenter cavaliers à 6 on va
jouer des ventes un peu différente un
pas toujours joué la même chose
cavalier prend ses 6 on va reprendre de
b 5 on va remettre la dame recettes
ça va jouer cavalier t5
ces quatre mal fou à 6 je connais pas
très bien cette variante mais b3 alors
je me demande ce n'est pas un coup qui
était embêtant ici qui était d'un match
4 je suis pas sûr que ce soit bon mais
je me rappelle c'était penny cette
variante ce qui a des idées de dan des
cats il ya des idées de fougue et quatre
échecs dames f3 tempo croire à écouter
les mecs
je dois vous avouer que je ne connais
pas
plus loin mais on a envie quand même de
tenter d'amener 4 parce que j'ai envie
de m'en prendre à la torah j'espère
quand même être un argument de poids 1
et sur qui on prend des cinq je
commencerai par fouquet quatre échecs
comme ça il sera obligé de mettre un
truc en d2 j'échangerais jeu prendra en
main sur échec vix ses variantes la mise
ici on l'avait pas recommandée dans le
répertoire c'est parce que on vous avait
dit que c'était une langue très
dangereuse donc là je sais par un
peut-être qui connaît la théorie est que
je fais n'importe quoi mais il est
possible sur une news is si on connaît
pas la théorie de perdre avec les blancs
juste d'un match 4 c'est un coup encore
théorique d'âmes damnées 3g pam a
fortiori d'amd 4 paraît fort et on peut
avec cette musique perdre en un coup
fait directement sorte de l'ouverture
premier coup des fêtes
c'est quelque chose qui est tout à fait
possible
on va voir mais là le truc c'est que la
tour en 1 pas très bien placé en plus on
peut même calais du dame prend 2,5 échec
parfois pour en plus récupérer le pion
voyez ce qui dure avec cette ouverture
c'est qu'il se retrouve avec une deux
trois fin toutes ces pièces mineurs et
nous on peut faire un coup mais quatre
échecs on peut avoir tout fait voyez la
centralisation des pièces noires les
pièces rares sont très bien placés donc
c'est très très très puissant
très très puissant
margot qui nous écrit pls je crois que
c'est le mot qui convient vrai on a
juste sorti un coup un théorique damage
quatre petites variantes et la dame à 4
pp pls en faire une petite musique ps92
télé qui participent à notre un autre
discorde
alors il a pris en d5 et là dessus je
comptais faire couper quatre échecs elle
vous disaient intermédiaires histoire de
venir taper 1 sur échec fera pas de mal
enfin un truc un peu fou des deux fous
prend cavaliers prend mais lecavalier en
premier alors là si je voulais prendre
war est comme ça s'ils prenaient en
raciste je voulais prendre en c1 et en
d2 en fait j'avais dans l'idée de tout
raser
il revient d'un est la dame et l'âge
avait pour idée de raser e5 maintenant
sur échec
vous parlez du pion e5 foods 2 et on va
lui laisser son fonds eux deux clous et
cavaliers cloud et tout est cloué on
allait faire rock et pour 2,8
on avait une qualité de plus si on
allait continuer à prendre du matos nous
et 7,7 me this notre ami amine tvi
connaissait la théorie jusqu'à b3d jouer
un coup d'un match 4 qui encore
théorique
je sais plus comment faire exactement
jouent avec les blancs mais enfin vous
faire un truc précis et ont du coup
premier coup qu'il a joué seule dame f3
d'amd 4 et c'était déjà terminé très
très très très dangereux
cette misys vous jouez un couard théorie
et c'est fini alors on va prendre encore
un 5 + 5 rose ann stores mots ce sera
peut-être le dernier on va rejouer alors
on va jouer des quatre corps change un
petit peu même inouï qui a pris une pl
ace alors cavaliers ici allez on va
jouer du logement est le pion c4 comme
ça on va sortir le pion devant le
cavalier qui viendront ces trois
derrière les pions pièce est désert les
pions que aussi ce qu'ils essaient trois
fous des cas très probablement va être
joué selanne in the indian donc qui va
essayer de clouer le cavalier pour nous
empêcher de jouer depuis le coup de 4
donc ou de thématiques 1 pour mettre le
pion au centre
on va faire dame ces deux pour ne pas se
faire doubler les pions
rock alors allez voyons va sortir le
fond angers 5
on veut clouer le cavalier et on veut
peut-être joué avec 4,1 pour pas perdre
le temps de faire deux trois quatre ans
ok on va garder le fond vous gardez la
paire de fou on va faire du cou ou trois
fous des trois et on jouera e46 on peut
dans un deuxième temps
et on verra comment il se débrouille du
cloud hp il devra revenir avec le fou en
hausse est un peu plus tard qu'elle on
va essayer de se faire plein sur cette
partie en poutre ans peut-être en
faisant du cavaliere 3g 4g 5
on va peut-être vouloir profiter de ce
pion à 6 ok donc sur e4 fou prend dame
prend cavaliers prend 1,4 fou prend des
huit cavaliers prend ces trois fous aux
7 on va pouvoir se venger sur la qualité
donc que 4 semble jouable ici un an phu
et c'est dur à tour 8 pardon donc ça
semble pas jouable donc je répète 4 fou
prend ces trois dames français trois
cavaliers prend 2,4 fou prend des huit
cavaliers france et roi fou et sept
tours 8
donc on va se faire un petit truc plus
tranquille où on va jouer f3 et e4 donc
un autre plan aussi un an ses positions
là pourront pour installer le centre
commencer par f3 pour jouer le 4 en
force
donc ils jouent des cinq coups très
logique et donc on va mettre le pion de
3 du coup je vais voir s'il allait faire
des 5
je ne savais pas sinon j'aurais joué
autrement je le joue un truc prendre le
sens de faire le truc pédagogique est ok
il se défend et on va essayer de la
jouer à la dure alors imaginons qu'on a
envie de faire un roc opposé pour
utiliser ce qu a pu si ce qui permet de
faire une zone de contact rapide en g5
c'est pas sûr que ce soit bon ici mais
bon c'est une idée qui existe et c'est
intéressant de la mettre en oeuvre c'est
à dire qu'on a vu ce qu'on voit ce couac
6 on a envie d'en profiter
et pour en profiter on joue le rock
opposé donc les noirs ils vont devoir
réagir très rapidement peut-être en
prenant et en jouant c5 ou en jouant c5
directement ce qui paraît quand même
très dangereux pour nous mais on va
essayer de voile rapidement joué comme
ça alors ça paraît être un bon coup
maintenant on a quand même envie de
prendre une fois ici j'imagine il ne
peut pas prendre avec le cavalier
puisqu'il est cloué c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça que j'aurais pu prendre plus tôt
et on va jouer g4 on va jouer à la très
barbare et on va voir ce que ça donne
honnêtement j'y crois pas du tout mais
c'est pourquoi pour finir avec une
partie un peu plus fun que les autres
prise
allez on va faire on va prendre de but
on va s'amuser on n'est pas très bien je
me dis d'un truc comme dams est très
dangereux même on va essayer de se faire
plaisir il fait ses quatre alors ses
cadres il croit pas du tout quand vous
jouez dans un contrat rock
il faut il faut ouvrir la position et la
c4 ça va me permettre de planquer mon
rang en d2 et de complètement me cachais
jeu sera entouré de pions et il me rend
un grand service
il a une nouvelle fois on lui pose une
question alors on va voir comment il
réagit
j'imagine qu'il doit surtout pas prendre
pour ça peut-être que j'ai cinq étaient
un peu rapide mais on va voir ok ça
c'est bien joué alors là on a deux
options peut rejouer la finale avec dame
prend hc3 pro-hg 6 fou prend des mythes
mon aura un pion de moins ou ou
continuer est ce qu'on veut faire f4
allez on va faire f 4 ça s'y prend on
reprend et on est content quand même
d'ouvrir la position même si c'est un
peu dangereux en a laissé la case de 4
et tout mais bon ok donc ils menacent le
pion
mais maintenant on va gagner du matériel
immédiatement aller très haut blanc
comment est ce qu'on continue à l'eso
blanc de jouer les blancs jouent et
gagnent du matériel white plein wind
mathieu long
les blancs jouent et gagnent du matos
dommage c'est exactement d'un proche cet
échec
roy prend forcé et g6
il faut prendre le set
petites tactiques sympa
tu pas si vous l'auriez vu en partie les
tontons on va revenir h4 avec le fou il
va prendre en d2 on va faire recours ont
trois affaires droit des deux on va
colmater le pion ses trois protégés
attaqué la tour en fera cavalier f3
cavalier e 5 rapidement ainsi prend pas
le pion ces cas demain donc il va
prendre va mettre l'euro en d2 on
protège ses trois la case d3 et protégé
s'est attaqué et on protège toutes les
cases de la troisième est maintenant
cavalier f3 je développe et cavaliers 5
je m'installe peut essayer de m'en
empêcher en mai
le cavalier 5 ça permettra de reprendre
de f
s'il prend et de remettre une bonne
structure comme ça voilà on a réarrangé
notre structure est maintenant on va
faire un truc comme flash trois tours
j'ai un tour f1 fouet f5 et on va
attaquer le roi à fond c'est exactement
ce qu'on va faire renaître le fourrage 3
on a nos fous qui brille les tours
peuvent la tour ce timide peut même pas
rentrer en jeu et ombrie de partout
et on est gagnant
avec notre petite caisse de plus
ce qu'on est vraiment faire je pensais
tour df quand même s'en prendre aux
pions f
car il voulait changer les pièces et pas
mal joué mais là on va alors on va pas
garder et à mettre le fou réussit donc
on va plutôt échangés on va mettre une
tour en f1 va être une tourangelle
peut-être plus tôt et on va doubler
tripler
quand tu leur avancée le pion métral
font un f6 un petit à petit progresser
carton g3 ça évitera les problèmes
peut-être une fois qu'il aurait mis la
tour là on mettra carrément le fou ici
on passera le fou probablement là pour
pour l'empêcher de houla
et voilà à force de trop parler on a
fait une connerie
il fallait qu'on finit sur un sur un
truc moche
il fallait qu'on finit sur un truc moche
bon allez goûter c'est pas très grave
affaire tour f1
on apprend lève 7
il fallait qu'on conclue sur un truc de
merde
mais bon va mettre la tour angers7 on
est quand même très bien mais mon tour
j'ai trois teams grosse erreur ça vous
arrive aussi dans vos parties
mais bon ça reste très très bien
qu'est-ce qu'on va se faire ce qu'on va
utiliser les deux tours 7e frais des
problèmes
quel idiot mais bon parfois grande à une
pièce de plus on se déconcentre
quand c'est un peu trop facile
il faut toujours faire attention
mais bon la position était juste faire
tout rejet de et tour g1 et l'idée que
je vous dise est de ramener le fou versé
5 et on aurait tapé les pions sur l'ale
dames et ça aurait été simple
mais toujours faire attention quand on
prend trop confiance aux retours de
flamme alors déjà pour commencer on va
faire un échec
il va devoir faire rager 8 on va faire
un deuxième échec qui va devoir faire
broyer fuite on fera tout reprend à
cette voie ça c'est une petite technique
à connaître ça vous permet de gagner un
pion et de menaces et mat
on croit g8 forcé tout rejet fc3f huit
tours prend à 7
il sera obligé de revenir en j8 allez
voir on va venir ici qui technique à
connaître on prend et comme ça on a
gagné le trait de nouveau à l'adversaire
de jouer mais il est obligé de jouer roi
g8
ou tour ici que j'avais pas vu bon j'ai
l'impression que ma concentration n'est
plus là mais bon quasi obligé donc là on
va lui mettre un échec
il va faire tour g 8
on va aller choper ce pion
ce qui est plutôt bien pour nous parce
que surtout recettes la tour f 6 échecs
roi huit tours à huit échecs croit 17
tours prend g8 donc ok ils montrent la
tour mais on va monter le roi henri iii
et on a toujours l'idée de faire torah
je suis tour g8 forcé et tout reprend
et là on fait tout rage suite matt tout
bêtement mais c'est un problème parce
que ces deux tours mont-royal nous
permettait de l'union pea nous ont
permis de raser ses pions parce qu'on en
a déjà rasé 3 2 on enverra un troisième
mais bon en gros la partie aurait été
propre
sans le tour j'ai 3 il aurait failli
faire tour j'ai deux tours ici et quand
la tournée en g8 passer de l'autre côté
avec le fou est sur b4 sûrement joué un
truc avec l'a3 et l'empêchait de pousser
ou même ramené la tour en b1 pourquoi
parent sur à 5 on aurait pu faire à
trois tours des humbles ok ça mais
ramené après notre fou un moment donné
de ce côté-là et gagner de l'autre côté
bon mon nom eût à 4 du coût pour clouer
le pion b avec le foie ans et les tours
les tours doublé et on aurait gagné la
partie de manière plus propre mais bon
ça a bien marché aussi
j'espère que ça vous a plu
ce petit stream c'est un style comme
vous est complètement différent de ce
qu'on a l'habitude s'entend au timbre de
voix et dans la manière de parler on est
moins brutaux je sais pas si vous
préférez ceux ne préférait pas si vous
aimez tôt si vous aimez tout donc
n'hésitez pas à écrire dans le chatt
rapidement et puis on va se on va se
quitter
petit à petit enfin petit à petit à se
quitter de but en blanc d'ailleurs 12
et donc sera de retour jeudi prochain
pour un autre stream
merci tout le monde je vous laisse
écrire dans le discorde pour ceux qui le
souhaitent tout alla on va laisser
l'antenne au prochain stream
merci les tentes ont passé une
excellente soirée un excellent week end